This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars and this is the sound of well here I'm gonna play you the sound and if you're old enough you'll be able to identify it right away That's the sound of a brand new cassette tape being unwrapped and put into a cassette deck That's my friend and fellow radio tobian Benjamin Walker He hosts the show Theory of everything and he's definitely old enough to know that sound. Yeah, well, so are you, pal. Benjamin is sitting in a car. A car that happens to have a tape deck, with Andrea Hart, who works with these sub-pop
这里是99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯，这是……好吧，我这就放给你们听。如果你年纪够大，你马上就能认出来。那是崭新的盒式磁带被拆开并放入卡式录音机时的声音。那是我的朋友兼广播同行本杰明·沃克。他主持节目《万物理论》，他绝对老到能听出这个声音。没错，老兄，你也是。本杰明正坐在一辆车里。这辆车刚好配有卡式录音机，旁边是安德烈娅·哈特，她与这些独立流行音乐
record label. At first when we started doing the cassettes for every release. If you're not familiar with sub-pop, it's kind of this small, but really mighty record label that is signed some of the best indie bands in the last 30 years. Nirvana, Slater Kenny, the postal service, Beach House, and Andrea has a job at Subpop that a lot of people might not imagine exists at a modern record label. I work at Subpop Records doing cassette production. It's crazy, I just don't think I've even held a cassette in my hand for a long time. This job, handling cassette production at Subpop, it disappeared completely for a while. But recently, record stores and distributors have been requesting Subpop to release their titles on cassette.
唱片公司合作。起初，当我们开始为每张新专辑制作磁带时。如果你对Sub Pop不熟悉，它是一家规模不大但实力雄厚、在过去30年里签下了一些最优秀的独立乐队的唱片公司。Nirvana、Sleater-Kinney、The Postal Service、Beach House，而安德烈娅在Sub Pop的工作，是许多人可能想象不到现代唱片公司会存在的岗位。我在Sub Pop Records负责磁带制作。这太疯狂了，我简直觉得我已经好久没把磁带拿在手里了。这份在Sub Pop处理磁带制作的工作，曾有一段时间彻底消失了。但最近，唱片店和分销商一直在要求Sub Pop将他们的专辑发行磁带版。
And Subpop asked Andrea to oversee the operation. I don't like nostalgia for the sake of it, and it's clear to me why cassettes have been replaced now a couple of times over by more convenient mediums, mediums where you can actually skip tracks and you don't have to rewind when you're down listening. But I do think there are a lot of good things about the cassette. First off, you can fix a messed up cassette with some patience and a pencil. Plus, there's never been a better way to make a mix. And you can have a tape floating around to the floor of your car for years and then
于是Sub Pop请安德烈娅来监督这项业务。我不喜欢为怀旧而怀旧，我也很清楚为什么磁带现在已经被更便捷的媒介取代了好几次，在那些媒介里你可以随意切歌，听完也不用倒带。但我确实觉得磁带有很多优点。首先，只要有点耐心和一支铅笔，你就能修好一张卡壳的磁带。此外，从来没有比这更好的方式来制作混音带了。你可以把一盘磁带随手扔在车厢地板上好几年，然后
throw it in your tape deck and it sounds great. Well, it sounds okay. It never really sounded great. In any case, subpop is betting that some of us will want to hear our favorite albums on Cassette again. But there is one population that never stopped listening to music on Cassette. That's filmmaker Alex Lambert. We've been working together on this story and actually I'm just going to hand it over to her now. The United States Prison System has the largest prison population in the world. And when the more than two million prisoners in this country have access to music, it's often on cassette. Well, my number one thing to keep around here is my walkman, my tape, my legal papers, and some bottle water.
把它塞进录音机，听起来依然很棒。好吧，听起来还行。它其实从来没真正好听过。无论如何，Sub Pop在赌，我们当中会有人想要再次在磁带上听到自己最喜欢的专辑。但有一个群体从未停止用磁带听音乐。那就是电影制片人亚历克斯·兰伯特。我们一直在合作这个故事，实际上我这就把话筒交给她。美国监狱系统拥有世界上最多的囚犯人口。当这个国家两百万多名囚犯有机会接触音乐时，通常是通过磁带。嗯，我在这里必须带在身边排第一的东西是我的随身听、我的磁带、我的法律文件，还有一些瓶装水。
Yeah, they can have everything else. That's Adolfo Davis. At 14 years old, he was involved in a gang related shooting. He was tried as an adult in sentence to life in prison. Adolfo is 39 now, and he's serving his sentence at Stateville Correctional Center in Illinois. Listening to music on tapes is one of his only means of escape. In 1990 the year Adolfo was incarcerated. Everybody was listening to music on Gazette tapes. In fact, Adolfo had some with him when he went to prison.
是的，其他东西他们都可以拿走。那是阿多尔福·戴维斯。14岁时，他卷入了一起黑帮枪击案。他被当作成年人审判，并被判处终身监禁。阿多尔福现在39岁了，他在伊利诺伊州的斯蒂特维尔惩教中心服刑。用磁带听音乐是他在里面仅有的逃避现实的途径之一。1990年，也就是阿多尔福入狱的那一年。每个人都在用盒式磁带听音乐。事实上，阿多尔福进监狱时身上就带着一些磁带。
Yeah, I got locked up with a Waltman and I think my sentence tape, yeah, when I was in the field, drugs, I have a fanny pack. And I have my Waltman and my fanny pack with my tape. And I've been listed to the Waltman while I'm watching out for security for the police. A fanny pack. We usually call it a couch, but it's a fanny pack. Let's be real. Just a few years after Adolfo was locked up, the cassette tape would be all but replaced
对，我被关进去时带了一个随身听，还有我的……我想是判决时的磁带，对，当我在街头混的时候，我有个腰包。我的腰包里装着随身听和磁带。当我在为警察的安全巡逻放哨时，我一直在用随身听听歌。一个腰包。我们通常叫它小包，但它就是个腰包。说实话吧。就在阿多尔福被关进去几年后，盒式磁带几乎就要被淘汰了
by the CD out here in the free world. But in prison, the cassette they've done. I've been telling my family family that I need order tape and the younger generation that I can tell soon, they don't even know what the tape is. And not just any old cassette tape is allowed in prison. Some prisons require a very specific type of cassette tape. It has to be clear, it has to be sonically welded
被外面自由世界的CD所取代。但在监狱里，磁带还在。我一直在告诉我的家人，我需要订购磁带，而我很快能接触到的年轻一代，他们甚至不知道磁带是什么。并不是随便什么旧磁带都能带进监狱的。有些监狱对盒式磁带的要求非常具体。它必须是透明的，必须经过超声波焊接
so it can't be taken apart and put back together, and the box it goes in has to also be perfectly clear. That's Steve Step, owner of National Audio Company, America's pre-eminent manufacturer of cassette tapes. The reason you can't have a five-screw cassette or maybe a colored cassette that's opaque, is they don't want a razor blade or narcotics or something else to be enclosed in a cassette. They do have people in the correctional facilities who look at and inspect incoming materials and they have to be able to see through or they won't allow them in. Steve has gotten familiar with this subfield of cassette tape manufacturing, even though it is not the focus of his business. Mostly he makes normal cassette tapes for a number of different markets. Music labels, spoken word,
这样它就不能被拆开又重新组装，而且它装磁带的盒子也必须是完全透明的。那是史蒂夫·斯泰普，美国国家音频公司的老板，该公司是美国最杰出的盒式磁带制造商。你不能使用五颗螺丝的磁带，也不能使用不透明的彩色磁带，原因在于他们不希望刀片、毒品或其他东西被藏在磁带里。惩教机构里有人负责检查和审核进来的物品，他们必须能够看透磁带，否则就不允许带入。史蒂夫对磁带制造的这个细分领域已经很熟悉了，尽管这并不是他业务的重点。他主要为各种不同的市场制作普通的盒式磁带。音乐唱片公司、有声读物、
audio books. Steve's factory in Springfield, Missouri produces both blank tapes and tapes with audio already on them. The machines collate all those parts together, transfer them across on a conveyor, and then wrap them with cellophane and put a tear strip in. Steve was one of the first people in the cassette industry, and he's one of the only people still in it. We're the only people I know of. Most of the people left in the cassette industry are mom-and-pop shops or small operations. If you purchased a cassette recently from anywhere, from Renewashack or from the merch table of some punk band you saw live, it probably started out in Steve's factory. His company ships out up to 100,000 cassettes a day.
有声书。史蒂夫位于密苏里州斯普林菲尔德的工厂既生产空白磁带，也生产已经录制好音频的磁带。机器将所有这些零件组合在一起，通过传送带运送过去，然后用玻璃纸包装并加上易撕条。史蒂夫是磁带行业的第一批从业者之一，也是目前仅存的业内人士之一。据我所知，我们是唯一的一家。磁带行业剩下的多半是夫妻店或小型作坊。如果你最近在任何地方买过磁带，无论是从RadioShack还是从你看现场演出的某个朋克乐队的周边摊位，它很可能是从史蒂夫的工厂里生产出来的。他的公司每天发货多达10万盘磁带。
And a small number of those cassettes are special orders for prisoners, made with clear plastic and without screws. Once the tape's leaf here, we don't really see where they end up. As for why cassettes have stuck around in prisons all these years, it's hard to get a definite answer because every prison is different. But there's one theory we heard from a few different people. Tapes are allowed because CDs are easier to weaponize. They say that it's the most safest way for them to listen to music because a CD you could break and
其中有一小部分磁带是为囚犯定制的特殊订单，使用透明塑料制成且没有螺丝。一旦磁带离开这里，我们真的就不知道它们最终去了哪里。至于为什么磁带能在监狱里历经多年保留下来，很难得到一个确切的答案，因为每个监狱的情况都不同。但我们从好几个人那里听到了一种理论。之所以允许磁带存在，是因为CD更容易被制成武器。他们说，这是他们听音乐最安全的方式，因为CD可以被砸碎，而且
maybe cut somebody with. That's Chris Barrett. This tape of him was recorded a couple years ago for a short film. Chris used to run a service that helped families and packages to people in prison in New York State. He had a warehouse full of items that had already been approved by the prison authorities. Everything from food, clothing, boxer shorts, and yeah, cassettes instead of CDs. But he never really understood the logic behind it. They let me sell tuna fish cans that you know you pull off the top and that thing is metal like it's much more dangerous than a CD is my point, the tuna fish can and the CD. So I don't know why they come up with some of the rules that they come up with. We just try to stay within those guidelines.
也许还能用来割伤别人。那是克里斯·巴雷特。这段关于他的录音是几年前为一部短片录制的。克里斯过去曾经营过一项服务，帮助纽约州的家属给监狱里的人寄送包裹。他的仓库里堆满了已经获得监狱当局批准的物品。从食物、衣物、平角短裤，应有尽有，没错，还有用来替代CD的磁带。但他始终不明白背后的逻辑。他们允许我出售金枪鱼罐头，你知道的，你把顶盖拉开，那东西是金属的，比CD危险得多，这就是我的意思，金枪鱼罐头和CD。所以我不知道他们为什么会想出那些规矩。我们只是试着在这些准则之内行事。
Chris, whose package sending service recently went out of business, also sold a lot of cassette walkmins. Walkmins used to be available for purchase in prison commissaries, but they generally aren't anymore, which makes them extremely coveted items. And where and tear is not the only threat to the life of a walkman? Quarantare is not the only threat to the life of a walkman. Well, when it's like a major shakedown and they bring other officers from other institutions, they would just break your TV, break your radio, take your TV, take your radio, take your concept tape. Once you screw in my walkman, I cannot get another walkman.
克里斯的包裹寄送服务最近倒闭了，他也曾销售过大量的卡式随身听。随身听过去可以在监狱的内部小卖部买到，但现在通常买不到了，这使得它们成了极其抢手的物品。而损耗并不是随身听生命的唯一威胁。损耗并不是随身听生命的唯一威胁。嗯，当发生大规模的大搜查时，他们会从其他监狱调来其他警官，他们会直接砸碎你的电视，砸碎你的收音机，拿走你的电视，拿走你的收音机，拿走你的磁带。一旦我的随身听被没收了，我就不可能再弄到另一个随身听了。
It's probably one of the most prized items for theft. People try to hold out as much as they can, protect as much as possible. That's Efron Paredes Jr. He was a 15-year-old honor student when he was tried as an adult on a murder charge and sentenced to life without parole. He's always maintained his innocence. Efron is 43 now. And during his 28 years in prison, he amassed a pretty big collection of music.
这可能是最容易招致偷窃的物品之一。人们尽量苦苦支撑，尽最大可能保护它。那是小埃弗龙·帕雷德斯。当他因谋杀罪被当作成年人审判并被判处不得假释的终身监禁时，他还是个15岁的荣誉学生。他一直坚称自己是无辜的。埃弗龙现在43岁了。在监狱度过的28年里，他积攒了相当大的一批音乐收藏。
So my favorite would probably be a Kendrick Lamar, I like young GZ, Rick Ross, Nick Mills, I like the Wayne. At Muskegon Correctional Facility in Michigan, where Eferna is serving his sentence, prisoners can actually have MP3 players. Inmates can purchase an MP3 player through the prison commissary and then download music to it through a kiosk provided by a company called Access Entertainment. Before downloading, they have to transfer money to the company and receive a credit for a certain amount of songs.
所以我的最爱可能应该是肯德里克·拉马尔，我喜欢杨·吉兹、里克·罗斯、尼克·米尔斯，我喜欢韦恩。在密歇根州的马斯基根惩教中心，也就是埃弗龙服刑的地方，囚犯其实可以拥有MP3播放器。犯人们可以通过监狱小卖部购买MP3播放器，然后通过一家名为“接入娱乐”的公司提供的自助终端将音乐下载到播放器上。在下载之前，他们必须向该公司转账，并获得相应金额的歌曲点播额度。
But there's a catch. And Michigan there's a policy that they try to restrict as much music that would be labeled as parental advisory. In other words, the state of Michigan will try and sentence a 15 year old as an adult, but when he becomes an actual adult, the state won't let him purchase music deemed inappropriate for a teenager. It's interesting that, you know, the Department of Corrections has never taken any steps to restricting cassette tape purchases. We couldn't confirm that there were no restrictions on cassette music, but Eiffren hasn't encountered
但这里有个问题。在密歇根州有一项政策，他们试图尽可能限制那些会被贴上“家长指引”标签的音乐。换句话说，密歇根州会试图把一个15岁的孩子当成成年人判刑，但当他真正成为成年人时，州政府却不让他购买被认为不适合青少年的音乐。有趣的是，你知道，惩教部门从未采取任何措施来限制盒式磁带的购买。我们无法证实对磁带音乐没有任何限制，但埃弗龙从未遇到过
them. And that's why he says a lot of inmates still prefer cassettes. They listen to them all the time, on their personal walkmins and sometimes out loud. Actually, as we're talking right now, there's a gentleman in the bathroom washing clothes with his radio lines playing the song, play at your own risk. Writer, near the part of the prison where E-Fren is locked up is the wing that houses the prisoners in solitary confinement. We hear guys all the time yelling up to us saying, hey turn the music on, turn some music
它们。这就是为什么他说很多犯人仍然更喜欢磁带。他们一直在听，用他们自己的随身听，有时还大声放出来。事实上，就在我们谈话的时候，浴室里有一位先生正在洗衣服，他的收音机里放着这首歌，歌名叫《后果自负》。作家，在埃弗龙被关押的监狱区域附近，是关押单独禁闭犯人的侧楼。我们经常听到有人向我们大喊大叫，说，嘿，把音乐打开，放点音乐
on, you know, turn on, turn Rick Ross on, turn on Meet Meal. Hey, this is what they've been waiting for. You know, something so that they can hear down there. You ready? Something that's, you know, something so that they can hear down there. You ready? Something that's, you know, music from upstairs. Uh. I used to break the times like this, the rhyme like this, so I had to grind like that,
开着，你知道的，打开，把里克·罗斯的歌打开，把梅尔·米尔的歌打开。嘿，这就是他们一直在等待的。你知道，能让他们在下面听到点东西。准备好了吗？能让他们，你知道的，在下面听到点东西。准备好了吗？有些，你知道的，来自楼上的音乐。呃。我以前这样押韵，像这样押韵，所以我必须那样拼搏，
the shine like this, and the matter of time I spent on some locked up issues, and the back of the petty wagon, cuss locked on wrist, see my dreams unfold. Night man's control. It was time to marry. Prisons tend to be late adopters of technology. So maybe one day all prisons in the US will just make the switch from cassette to digital. Or maybe they'll go to CDs first just to
像这样闪耀，我花在某些被锁上的问题上的时间，以及在囚车后面的时间，手铐锁着手腕，看着我的梦想破灭。黑夜男人的控制。是时候结婚了。监狱往往是新技术的晚期采用者。所以也许有一天，美国所有的监狱都会直接从磁带转向数字化。或者他们可能会先转向CD，只是为了
be illogically chronological. Whatever the format, the most important thing about music to E-friend and Adolfo is escape and connection. Here's the Delphiwe again. Music connect us all together. Everybody shed music each other. You know, music allows everyone to escape in this place. I can't, I can't do it without my music. In a day I rest my Waltman. I'll borrow Waltman from somebody else to live stay Waltman. So I can go to sleep. The days that you don't have your walk, man.
不按常理按时间顺序来。不管是什么格式，对埃弗龙和阿多尔福来说，音乐最重要的意义在于逃避现实与建立连接。再次有请阿多尔福。音乐将我们所有人连接在一起。每个人都与彼此分享音乐。你知道，音乐让每个人在这个地方得以逃避。我不能，没有音乐我真的过不下去。有一天我让我的随身听休息一下。我会从别人那里借一个随身听来维持生活。这样我才能入睡。那些你没有随身听的日子，
No, like I play my walk man like three days, then I let it rest like two days. Wow, he rests his walkman. That is love. 99% invisible was produced this week by Benjamin Walker and Alex Lambert with Katie Mingle, Sam Green's fans to review Seth Kirk Cole's dead Delaney Hall Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars. The audio you heard from Chris Barrett the guy who sent packages to prisoners was from the film The Prison in 12 Landscapes by Brett Story for more information about where and how to see that
不，就像我玩随身听三天，然后让它休息两天。哇，他让他的随身听休息。这就是真爱。本杰明·沃克和亚历克斯·兰伯特本周制作了99% Invisible，参与制作的还有凯蒂·明格、萨姆·格林斯潘、赛斯·柯克科尔、德兰尼·霍尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼以及我罗曼·马尔斯。你听到的克里斯·巴雷特（也就是那个给犯人寄包裹的人）的音频片段来自布雷特·斯托里的电影《12个风景中的监狱》，欲了解关于这部电影的更多信息和观看方式，请访问
film go to PrisonLandscapes.com. Special thanks to Elise Blenderhassich, he introduced us to both Atalfo and Ephraim. A slightly different version of this story will air on Benjamin Walker's theory of everything. Benjamin is one of my oldest friends in radio and you should definitely be friends with him too, but in case you don't already listen, this is one of my favorite clips from his program that has a little bit more Benjamin Walker in it. Enjoy. There's this painting that I keep with me, always. It's one of those little postcard reproductions. I've even made a gold frame for it at a balsa wood.
PrisonLandscapes.com。特别感谢伊莉斯·布伦德尔哈西奇，她把阿多尔福和埃弗龙介绍给了我们。本杰明·沃克的《万物理论》节目将播出这个故事的一个略有不同的版本。本杰明是我在广播界最老的朋友之一，你们也绝对应该和他做朋友，但如果你还没听过，这是我最喜欢的他的节目片段之一，里面有更多本杰明的风格。请欣赏。有这样一幅画，我一直带在身边。它是那种明信片大小的复制品。我甚至用轻木为它做了一个金框。
The painting is called The Artist in His Studio. It's by John Singer Sargent. I've brought it with me here to the studio. I have it right here in front of me, propped up next to the microphone. The painting depicts a man painting a picture in his studio. But this artist studio is not an ordinary studio. It is the artist's home.
这幅画叫《画室里的艺术家》。作者是约翰·萨金特。我把它带到了这里的录音室。它就在我面前，斜靠在麦克风旁边。画中描绘了一个人在自己的画室里作画。但这位艺术家的画室不是普通的画室。这是艺术家的家。
The man has his painting propped up on the bed and the bureau. There is no easel. You get the idea that the only things in the room are the bed, the Bureau, and the chair upon which the man sits. The man is confined to extremely small quarters. The setting is grim, and it contrasts with the painting that the man is working on. A landscape. The man is painting a landscape. Horses meander through a soft green meadow, and the trees are lush and full, and the blue horizon is dotted with clouds.
这个人的画作斜靠在床铺和衣柜上。没有画架。你会觉得房间里仅有的东西就是床、衣柜，以及这个人坐的椅子。这个人被限制在极其狭小的空间里。环境很严酷，这与他正在创作的画作形成了鲜明对比。一幅风景画。这个人正在画风景画。马儿在柔和的绿色草地上漫步，树木郁郁葱葱，蓝色的地平线上点缀着朵朵白云。
Most sergeant commentators dismiss this painting. They consider it to be nothing but a silly joke, an artist painting a landscape in his cramped doleful bedroom. But I consider this painting to be a masterpiece, because it captures the idea that through art man is able to transcend his dismal, squal surroundings. This painting is not a joke. This artist is not painting a landscape. This artist is painting a window.
大多数评论萨金特的人都对这幅画不屑一顾。他们认为这不过是个愚蠢的笑话，一个艺术家在他那狭窄阴暗的卧室里画风景画。但我认为这幅画是一杰作，因为它捕捉到了这样一种理念：通过艺术，人类能够超越他那阴暗、凄凉的周围环境。这幅画不是个笑话。这位艺术家画的不是风景画。这位艺术家画的是一扇窗户。
Look out this window for a moment. Here let me move out of your way. You'll find the view is breathtaking. I've spent my entire life looking for the way to get to the other side of this window. I've been told time and time again that I'm wasting my efforts, but I've never given up. I've always known that there is a way to break the glass and crawl out over the window so I've always been certain of it and I made a vow that I would never give up
看一眼这扇窗户。来，让我让开。你会发现这里的景色令人叹为观止。我花了一生时间寻找通往这扇窗户另一端的方法。一次又一次有人告诉我，我在白费力气，但我从未放弃。我一直都知道，有一种方法可以打破玻璃，从窗户爬出去，对此我一直坚信不疑，我发誓我绝不放弃
until I discovered the secret. You're snickering at me. Well, go ahead and run. You think I'm crazy for believing that there's something on the other side of this window. Well, I'm not. The reality on the other side is just as real as the one we stand in right now. Sometimes, I think it's even more real. But we do not have to go into that now. I have not brought you here to this window to discuss the metaphysics of reality. I have brought you here to this window because I need your help.
直到我发现这个秘密。你在对冷笑。好吧，尽管笑吧。你认为我疯了，才会相信这扇窗户的另一边有什么东西。好吧，我没有。另一边的现实和我们现在站立的现实一模一样真实。有时候，我觉得它甚至更真实。但我们现在不必讨论这个。我带你来这扇窗户前不是为了讨论现实的形而上学。我带你来这扇窗户前是因为我需要你的帮助。
You see, I believe that I have finally discovered the secret. So I'm going to go to the other side of the studio now, and I need you to kneel down here in the front. I'm going to count to three, and on three, I'm going to run towards you, and you are going to lift me into the air. You're going to have to poke me through the window. Trust me, this is going to work. With your help I am going to break the glass and land on the other side. So on three. One. Two.
你看，我相信我终于发现了这个秘密。所以我要走到画室的另一边去了，我需要你在这里跪到前面来。我数到三，数到三的时候，我会向你跑来，你要把我托到空中。你得把我从窗户里推过去。相信我，这行得通的。在你的帮助下，我将打破玻璃，降落在另一边。所以，数到三。一。二。
Three. That's the introduction to something will happen soon, an episode from Benjamin Walker's theory of Everything, from Radio Topia. 99% of visible is a project of KALW-91.7 in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, in architecture and interiors firm. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. It follows all on Twitter and Instagram, but the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world.
三。这是来自RadioTopia旗下本杰明·沃克的《万物理论》节目的某一集的开场，稍后将发生一些事情。99% Invisible是旧金山KALW-91.7的一个项目，由位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑与室内设计公司ArcSign的办公室制作。你可以通过Facebook找到并喜欢这个节目。它在Twitter和Instagram上关注所有人，但探索塑造我们世界设计的99% Invisible活动的最佳方式，
It's to spend as much time as possible on 99 bi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就是尽可能多地花时间浏览 99pi.org。来自PRX的Radio Topia。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。